this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by the Royal Air Force
and the Briggs automotive company who
are currently holding an engineering
design competition for young engineers
one of the moments that will always
stand out in my life is watching the joy
and excitement of the engineers at JPL
celebrating the monumental task they had
just completed they had just landed a
900 kilogram Rover the size of a Mini
Cooper on another planet the Mars rover
is bursting at the seams with
engineering innovation I could detail
the insane landing process and any of
the multitude of engineering marvels
onboard but today I want to discuss
something you may not have put much
thought into something we use every day
on earth
tires the wheels of the Mars rover have
been one of the biggest technical
difficulties encountered on the mission
the growing substantial damage through
the rough martian terrain surely the
engineers at NASA could have predicted
this and designed something better
well not everything is as simple as it
may seem even on flat hard ground the
rover has a top speed of 0.15 kilometers
per hour yet this snail's pace still has
enough force to tear holes into the
aluminium wheels of the rover the
engineers have some strict criteria that
made the job more difficult the wheels
need to be stiff enough to support the
weight of the rover nearly one ton that
isn't an easy task the wheels need to be
as light as possible to reduce launch
costs and must be able to maintain
traction and navigate the unpredictable
Martian terrain the current record
holder for the longest journey on an
extraterrestrial body is held by the
opportunity Rover at forty five
kilometers with the previous record
being held by the Russian Luna cod to a
lunar rover curiosity has racked off
just 20 kilometers today's all Mars
rovers have used solid aluminium wheels
the Sojourner opportunity and spirit
Rovers all used the design successfully
but the Curiosity rover is much heavier
each wheel on the Curiosity rover is
about half a meter in diameter and 400
millimeters wide milled from a solid
block of aluminium in a similar fashion
to the methods described in my
Bloodhound SSC video but unlike the
Bloodhound the Mars rover wheels are
milled to just 0.75 millimeters thick
over the majority of its circumference
damage here isn't all that surprising
0.75 millimeters thick is the same
thickness as a credit card running a
nearly one ton vehicle over a sharp rock
would be expected to damage aluminium
that thick NASA simply underestimated
the roughness of the terrain more warmly
though the load-bearing threads which
are about six point four millimeters
thick are also damaged and if they
continue to break the wheels will become
useless the Mars rover costs two point
five billion dollars to develop and it
employs a nuclear reactor for power
extending the life of this project was
top priority for its engineers and so
finding a solution to this problem has
been fairly high on NASA's list for
future projects
so what other designs could we use to
reduce the chances of the wheels
experiencing a stress that could damage
them we want them to be able to bend and
conform to the terrain this is what a
rubber airfield tires do on earth Land
Rovers drive over similar rough terrain
without any major problem so why not use
tires like this on Mars temperatures on
Mars can dip as low as minus a hundred
and thirty degrees Celsius temperatures
this low would transform rubber from an
elastic material capable of absorbing
stress to a brittle glass-like material
making it useless for this application
rubber would also degrade from the UV
radiation it would be exposed to on the
surface of Mars on top of this weight
savings is also top priority and rubber
wheels with thick rubber steel
reinforcements and a rim are actually
quite heavy the lunar rover used
flexible steel mesh wheels with a
stiffer inner frame to prevent over
deflection and thin strips of metal
attached to prevent the wheel from
sinking into the lunar soil this option
was studied for applications on Mars but
the lunar rover had a mass of just 450
kilograms compared to the 900 kilograms
of the Curiosity rover combined this
with the higher gravity on Mars and it
made the wheel unsuitable for the
application the wheels would simply not
be able to hold the weight of the
vehicle without deforming permanently
but Goodyear who developed the original
lunar wheel has been working alongside
NASA and in 2010 they were given the R&D
100 award for this spring tire which
could be the solution to our problems
being both light capable of bending and
conforming to the terrain without
permanently deforming and capable of
holding the weight of the heavier
so what's a secret what makes this
spring tire different to the ones on the
lunar rover they use a new age material
that has some incredible properties not
just for applications in space but right
here on earth
this spring tire uses a material called
nitinol nitinol is a nickel titanium
alloy that has been named a shape-memory
alloy and for good reason you can bend
and deform it and then just apply a
little bit of heat and it magically
returns to its original shape it
remembers its original shape that is
incredible but nothing is magic in this
world and everything has an explanation
here is how it works typically when a
material is stressed one of two things
can happen if the stress is below its
yield point the material will deform
elastically like a rubber band and
return to its original shape when the
stress is released alternatively if the
material is stressed beyond its yield
point the material will deform
permanently and when the stress is
released the material will not return to
its original shape so how does this
permanent deformation occur if the bonds
are not broken the material should
return to its original preferred crystal
lattice orientation but when sufficient
force is applied small defects in the
crystal lattice are able to move this is
what is happening to the wheels of the
Mars rover when driving over pointed
rocks and gravel the stress exceeds the
yield stress and thus the wheels are
gradually picking up permanent
deformation and eventually cracks will
form and the material will fracture
deformation occurs slightly differently
for night now as it has some unique
properties due to the internal crystal
structure when nitinol is below a
certain temperature it has a crystal
structure called martensite its crystal
structure is arranged in such a way that
it can accommodate deformation very
easily martensitic Nighthawk forms
grains of twinned atoms where the
direction aligns when stress is applied
these twin grains to form an align to
best absorb the stress particular twin
grains can grow at the expense of others
this is called d twinning this like the
dislocation movement in other metals is
permanent without external energy
providing the energy needed to revert
backwards but not all can get that
energy from heat upon heating the
nitinol forms austenite an ordered
regular crystal structure which
effectively resets the crystal structure
and when the night now cools again the
night all remembers its original shape
what makes night mall even more amazing
unuseful is that this transformation
temperature can be tailored for
different applications in general
increasing the titanium content of the
metal will increase the transformation
temperature this is an incredibly useful
property and it has found many
applications across many industries
let's say we want the metal to remember
its shape at 37 degrees Celsius body
temperature can you think of any
applications where this would be useful
I'll give you one traditionally when
stents which are tiny tubes used to
clear blockages in arteries are being
deployed a small balloon is used to
inflate it and plastically deform the
stent into shape
however this often places force on the
lining of the blood vessel which can
damage it and cause it to form scar
tissue many stent designs now employ
night not which has been tailored to
remember its shape at 37 degrees Celsius
and so when unshielded it automatically
expands into place without placing
excessive force on the blood vessel so
how is this useful for the Mars rover do
we have to apply heat to the metal so it
can recover its shape after running over
a particularly big rock no locally
nitinol can be induced into that
martensite to austenite transformation
through stress and strain and so when
the stress passes a threshold it
actually causes the crystal lattice to
transform to austenite and when the
stress is released it returns to
martensite and the metal recovers its
shape this is called super elasticity
and it is the property that allows these
new Mars rover wheels to deform right
down to the rim and still recover its
shape after this combined with the
interlocking coil design allows the tire
to tolerate strains in a way no other
tire could while surviving the harsh
Martian environment these tires could
appear in NASA's designs for future Mars
rovers like those plans for launch in
2020 it's easy to think something as
simple as a wheel will never be
reinvented but there are always ideas
and opportunities for people willing to
put the work into thinking about them
that's why i've teamed up with the Royal
Air Force and the Briggs automotive
company to bring you an exciting design
competition for young engineers we want
you to brainstorm designs for a numerous
transport vehicle that improves on
previous designs in some way we want
your most innovative and creative ideas
think from the ground up what problems
will the Mars rover encounter have you
ever thought about how we communicate
with a vehicle on another
the top prize winner will have their
idea developed and made into a 3d model
by the Briggs automotive company they'll
also win work experience at the
pioneering Bac Factory in Liverpool that
produces the world's only road-legal
single seater supercar for more
information head over to the starship
YouTube channel a link for that is on
screen now as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you would like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
[Music]